known being photographed shirtless and
alongside wild animals wraps at the same
time Vladimir Putin he's cultivated an
image as an intimidating and fearless
figure on the world stage he's a martial
arts expert
a fearless political actor and a former
spy his resume holds a certain cachet in
the West as a former KGB agent he's
automatically associated with secrecy
intimidation and the old fears Americans
had of the Soviet Union for much of the
21st century Putin has said of himself
that he lived a long time as an ordinary
person an ordinary miss all he wishes to
be for decades though he has been
anything but ordinary as he spent his
life climbing the ranks of the Russian
government moving farther and farther
away from his ordinary roots he was born
in some Petersburg in 1952 in the midst
of the Cold War Putin he had two older
brothers but unfortunately both died
during childhood
so Putin he was raised essentially as an
only child he was an atheist as a child
but today he's an Eastern Orthodox
Christian during Putin's childhood his
mother stayed at home and his father a
veteran of world war ii worked in a
factory as interesting aside here his
grandfather was a cook who worked for
Vladimir Lenin and even prepared meals
for Stalin a few times the Putin family
they lived in a communal apartment
shared by three families a home where
Putin says he used to hunt rats in the
stairwell perhaps a precursor to his
later fascination with hunting man's
with wild animals in general
now growing up Putin didn't prove
himself to be anything particularly
special in his early years but then by
the age of 12 he discovered athletic
competition it was in the midst of a
competition that Putin began to set
himself apart martial arts was his
chosen sport particularly sambo and judo
though his mother did not initially
approve of his participation in these
sports Putin proved himself to be a
worthy and skilled competitor in both at
one point his coach even showed up at
that Putin home to speak with his mother
about how much promise Vladimir showed
well it was actually that that did the
trick and his parents began to support
his athletic pursuits Putin now holds a
black belt in judo and has continued to
compete in both sambo and judo
establishing himself as the first world
leader to be at an advanced level in
these sports he also remains the
president of the same dojo he practiced
in while growing up though he
established himself as a ethically
talented Putin did not excel
academically in school during his
childhood he attended a local school for
his early years and then attended a
magnet school focused on chemistry he
didn't push himself but his teachers
thought that he did have potential and
they encouraged him to focus as much on
his schoolwork as he did on his martial
arts practice it was in the sixth grade
when Putin really began to push himself
and that showed in his grades he was
welcomed to the Young Pioneers the youth
group that was run by the Communist
Party this it was a serious mark of
Honor as Putin had previously been one
of only a few from the class who had not
been welcomed into the organization now
from 1970 to 1975 Putin continued his
studies at some Petersburg State
University while there he studied law
was required to join the Communist Party
he later left the party denouncing
communism in 1991 when he said / Marxism
Leninism this it became more and more
obvious for me or obvious truth that it
was nothing more than a beautiful and
harmful fairy tale that's in Petersburg
State University Putin met Anatoly
Sobchak who would become a key figure in
Putin's political success Sobchak was an
assistant professor at the school but he
actually went on to co-author the
constitution of the Russian Federation
and was also the first democratically
elected mayor of some Petersburg
[Music]
pootin graduated from San Petersburg
State University in 1975 and it was then
that he joined the KGB the KGB was the
Soviet Union Security Agency for much of
the 20th century it was creators in 1954
and continued to operate until 1991 when
the Soviet Union itself was dismantled
translated to English kg B stands for
State Security Committee it has a
reputation for oppression and monitoring
the actions and opinions of Soviet
citizens the KGB it was a truly
frightening organization for democracy
and an indication of the dangers of
communism to Westerners the organization
quelled rebellions we have two close eye
on anyone suspected to be an opposition
to the Soviet regime Putin started his
career with KGB in Leningrad but he was
later moved to Dresden Germany before
his transfer to Germany Putin married to
this very day Putin keeps his home life
a very private and information about his
family is very closely guarded he and
his wife lived milord were married from
1983 until the divorce in 2013 the
divorce it was seemingly amicable with
no specific reason given for it Vinod
Miller made references to Putin's
dedication to his work and the time
investment required tube servers world
leader they have two daughters together
Maria and yak Tarina both of whose lives
remain incredibly secrets they both used
fake names to go and register for
college and it's not entirely known in
which country either of the Putin
daughters currently lives in 2016
European newspapers even described Maria
as a secret daughter noting if she had
not been known to be photographed during
the entire length of Putin's time in
power for a former spy and a man with
many many enemies it's perhaps sensible
that his daughters have maintained this
secret life Putin indeed has status
either private life in which I do not
permit interference it must be respected
[Music]
so Putin he moved with his family to
Dresden where he served with the KGB for
five years he was fluent in German and
still speaks this language to this day
and he stated that he actually feels
more comfortable using German in English
Putin served in this Dresden post from
1985 to 1990 working as an undercover
agent playing the part of a translator
the work though not all of what Putin
did is known it was a spy after all it
wasn't particularly interesting much of
it was simply amassing information on
people ensuring that they remained loyal
to the Soviets and we're not plotting
any kind of revolution in 1989 though
the situation it became rather more
dicey for Soviets who were stationed in
Dresden during one incident as it became
more and more clear that East Germany
was falling out of Soviet control Putin
and his colleagues feared for their
lives as crowds stormed the KGB
headquarters in Dresden Putin called in
the Soviet military for help bird he was
told that nothing could be done for them
and less Moscow gave the order something
that Moscow never did while Putin and
his colleagues felt they survived their
day it had to become increasingly clear
that the situation was unstable during
this time Putin and other KGB agents
began burning fast so that when the day
came that their headquarters was
overtaken or abandoned or both no files
would be left in the hands of their
enemies the Berlin Wall fell in November
of 1989 and soon after Putin and his
family they returned to Russia by this
point
Putin held the rank of lieutenant
colonel in the KGB however the KGB was
nearing the end of its existence and
Putin was able to find work at the State
University of st. Petersburg he was no
ordinary professor though he was still
working for the KGB part of his job
included keeping an eye out for students
who showed promise as potential new KGB
recruits through his job Putin was also
able to reconnect with his former
professor and Nataly Saab jack Sobchak
he was elected the mayor of Petersburg
in 1991 and Putin joined his team as an
advisor he worked for Saab Jack until
1996 when Saab check a lost re-election
Putin could have opted to continue
working for his successor but Putin
believed the taking a job with subjects
political opponents would be disloyal
and he instead chose to move to Moscow
to begin working with the Yeltsin
administration during Boris Yeltsin's
presidency Putin rose through the ranks
first serving as deputy chief
administrator for the Kremlin Russia's
version of the White House and by 1999
he was named secretary of the Security
Council and became Yeltsin's chief
advisor on matters of foreign relations
and intelligence but it was then that
Putin's career got a real real boost
Yeltsin decided he didn't want to keep
his current prime minister so we got rid
of him that was in August of 1999 and
Putin well he was the beneficiary of
this decision as yeltsin named Vladimir
Putin to the post Yeltsin offered Putin
the position of a prime minister with
prospects somewhat foreshadowing the
next step in Putin's career because only
months after naming Putin as prime
minister Boris Yeltsin himself stepped
down and Vladimir Putin became the
Acting President of Russia and that was
in December of 1999 then only three
months later in March of 2000 Rutten he
was officially elected and became
president of Russia in his own right
[Music]
ten opponents run against him for
president but he won and for the first
time in Russia's history there was a
peaceful transfer of power to a
democratically elected presidents Putin
he used his first term to advocate for
certain international policies including
approval of the start to arms treaty and
improving relations with China Putin was
also initially supportive of the United
States's war on terror that followed the
9/11 terrorist attacks but he did not
support the United States's invasion of
Iraq during Putin's first summer in
power tragedy struck Russia when the
Kursk submarine sank in the Barents Sea
in August Putin he was on vacation when
the sinking occurred and he did not
immediately return home to address the
sinking and the deaths of all 118 crew
members who had been on board then when
he was asked what went wrong with the
Kursk Putin replied starkly that it sank
distraught an angry Russians were
attacking their president for his
handling or lack thereof of the Kursk
disaster
with some even accusing him of leaving
sailors to die when a rescue might have
stopped impossible the despite all of
this opinion polls showed that overall
his image did not sustain much damage
from the tragedy indeed four years later
the Kursk tragedy did not affect his
reelection at all
in 2004 the Russians reelected him to a
second term as their president and they
were apparently really pleased with the
job he was doing as Putin received over
70 percent of the vote
[Music]
during his first term in office Putin
had focused on economic reforms having
denounced communism he instead supported
an economic system that was essentially
capitalism with very strict regulations
and oversight after years of economic
struggle Russia was finally beginning to
see a stabilizing and even growing
economy under Putin some reports put
Russia's growth during his first term at
7% annually indeed he still remembered
favorably for this growth though it came
with increased nationalization of
Industry and in part because of the mid
2000s global financial crash the growth
did not last but in the country his
economy was in disarray for nearly the
entire decade before Putin's rise to
power an era of growth in which
disposable income nearly doubles was
reason for the people to think really
positively of Putin now Putin did work
on those economic policies we already
mentioned his first term but he also
made strides in Foreign Relations
including making a historic trip to
Israel this was the first ever trip by a
Russian leader to the country
conversations between Putin and Israeli
leaders focused largely on security
issues the tread pick garnered much
attention around the world as it came in
the midst of strengthening ties between
Russia and Israel though the two nations
disagreed on topics such as the Russian
sale of missiles to Syria the trip was
also seen as a move by Putin to help
secure Russia's position as a key
diplomatic actor in any Middle East
peace discussions or agreements now
security issues were present not just
abroad though Nan's homeland security
would become a major focus for Putin
unfortunately this is something that
became really clear during the horrific
tragedy at the Basilan school in 2014 in
September terrorists tailed over 1,000
people hostage at the best-known school
in North Ossetia nearly 800 of these
hostages they were children for three
days these terrorists demanding Chechen
independence from Russia held these
people hostage the situation had a
tragic ending when tanks rockets and
other artillery were used by the Russian
military to tried to clear the school
the special forces entered the school
after hearing the explosions from inside
where the hostages were being kept but
their actions they did not save lives
quite the contrary in the siege of the
school over 300 people died nearly
two-thirds of whom were children the
tragedy it shook the world and while the
government's was
of any wrongdoing initially the European
Court of Human Rights later stated that
Russia used excessive force and lacked
caution and they stormed the school
despite anger and discontentment at the
government's handling of the tragedy in
general it did not affect the public's
view of Putin very much at all quite the
opposite in fact a poll taken off to the
best of massacres stated that 83% of
Russians were still happy with him the
vessel and tragedy did lead to changes
in the halls of Russian power though
primarily giving more power to the
Russian presidents for instance instead
of electing governors in regions like
North Ossetia and Chechnya the president
would have the power to appoint
governors in 2007 during his second term
Putin was named Time magazine's Person
of the Year the magazine called the
final year of his second term is most
successful yet and the cover photo for
the issue a portrait of Putin one the
photographer the World Press Photo Award
during the shoot that you discussed
their mutual admiration for the Beatles
this connection helped Putin become more
comfortable and gave the photographer
the chance to get an award-winning shot
of the intimidating world leader no
matter how popular Putin was though the
Russian people could not elect him to a
third term the Russian Constitution
simply forbid it however Putin found a
way around this rule just when his time
in office was about to run out
[Music]
presidential terms in Russia had been
extended to six years but this change
did not benefit Putin he was beholden to
the previous constitutional rules so how
did you get to stay in power while the
man who was elected Russia's next
president was Dimitri Medvedev and he
was a protege of Putin's and have
benefited from Putin's rise to power
neither he nor Putin wanted Putin to be
pushed off the international stage and
so Medvedev named Putin as Russia's
Prime Minister a position he had
previously held under Boris Yeltsin
after 13 years in leadership Putin would
remain at the highest levels of Russia's
government he and his supporters were
able to keep him in power and stay in
line with the law although perhaps not
exactly in line with its exact intent
during his third term as Prime Minister
from 2008 to 2012 Putin focused on
dealing with the economic crisis that
swept the world as well as Russia's
population problems Russia's population
was falling by 1 million people a year
a devastating number for a country whose
population is only 150 million in 2010
the trend reversed and Russia's
population it began to grow the reversal
is in part credited to Putin's economic
reforms when people have more money it
is easier to support a larger family one
of Putin's economic reforms included
joining the World Trade Organization or
WTO in 2012 negotiations for Russia to
join the WTO lasted nearly two decades
as they had started after the fall of
the Soviet Union Russia was granted
entry into the WTO after negotiations
reached a point which granted Russia
permission to phase in the opening of
markets while it aligned with other WTO
trading requires
[Music]
now while this political party retains
dominance and Putin was again the
candidate for president in 2012 he did
not escape politically unscathed from
his maneuver to hold on to power by
sidestepping the term limits the
elections in 2012 for a heavily
protested with claims of fraud tainting
Putin's election to a third term the
task of the government is not only to
pour honey into a cup but sometimes to
give bitter medicine bars despite those
protests well he was inaugurated in May
of 2012 and this time his term would be
6 years this means that Putin will be
President of Russia until at least 2018
and with allegations of his interference
in United States elections his
prominence in the world well it only
seems to grow Putin has continued to be
reelected and reappointed to positions
at the highest level of Russian
governments but his time in office it's
not been without questions surrounding
his shady actions among the high points
or low points we should say of intrigue
surrounding Putin are the murders of
Russian journalists deaths of
journalists were a point of concern in
Russia long for Putin's rise to power
but the issue well it began to get a lot
of international attention during
Putin's second term as president when
journalist Anna Politkovskaya was
murdered this journalist had been a
strong critic of Putin and particularly
the war in Chechnya even before her
death she was even poisoned but
ultimately recovered her murder it
remains to this day unsolved but there
is suspicion that Putin and his
governments well maybe they targeted her
political sky is also far from the only
Putin opponent his death has occurred in
suspicious circumstances in March of
2017 the Washington Post even published
a list of 10 such deaths among these
deaths was a former Deputy Prime
Minister and Putin critic who was shot
outside the Kremlin he was a tycoon
whose death was initially called a
suicide but now that's rather unsure is
also a journalist who was kidnapped and
shot in the woods and a former KGB agent
he was found to be poisoned by Russian
agents then there's the journalist who
died of a mysterious illness and whose
medical records have been sealed
certainly not failing on any intrigue
[Music]
forget many of these deaths may never be
proven beyond doubt to be the work of
Putin's government one thing is
absolutely certain Vladimir Putin does
not like to be viewed as weak he has
done all he can to prove his strength
and show the world that he is strong and
manly beyond his active participation in
martial arts he shows his power and
dominance by hunting tracking and posing
with wild animals he's caught huge fish
including a forty six pound pike and
shot a crossbow at a whale only to
tranquilize it though he also once saved
a camera crew from a Siberian tiger that
was about to attack them while on a tour
of a Wildlife Sanctuary further he's
actually got close enough to polar bears
to attach a tracking device to them for
a research project now polar bears might
look cute and you might think this is
particularly dangerous but they're
actually incredibly vicious creatures
Putin has also attached himself to an
experimental flying machine to accompany
birds on migration and it's important to
note that he always does these things
carefully making sure that there are
photographers presence the more I know
about people the more I like dogs I like
simple animals when he's not hanging out
with wild animals Putin makes time for
other adventurous and athletic
activities he dives in the black seed
explores shipwrecks plays hockey ride
snowmobiles and motorcycles and has even
driven a Formula One race car once
during a visit to a Russian youth camp
he even challenged attendees to
arm-wrestle with him then not content
with armwrestling as a show of strength
he tried to bend a frying pan with his
bare hands
naturally there were photographers on
hand to capture all of these incredible
moments and the photos have been
distributed and widely viewed around the
world you've probably seen several of
them from his days at school cultivating
an athletic reputation to his time as
president and Prime Minister Putin has
made it known that he is a man to be
reckoned with
[Music]
during his most recent term as president
with couple years left go Putin has
found himself centered on the world
stage Russia has been involved in the
Syrian civil war supporting the
governments of Bashar al-assad in early
July of 2017 Vladimir Putin and Donald
Trump announced a ceasefire in
southwestern Syria and weeks later
Russia announced that it had signed a
deal with Syria allowing Russia to keep
its airbase in the country for at least
50 more years in addition to Syria
perhaps Putin's most talked about
involvement has been the alleged
interference of Russia in the u.s.
election from hacking allegations to
questions of illicit meetings and deals
with members of trumps in a circle the
US and the world media have made Putin
and his political dealings a household
conversation topic so Vladimir Putin he
began his life growing up in a communal
apartment in the midst of Russia during
the Cold War and has become an
internationally polarizing figure he's
been strong and unapologetic in his
foreign policy and use of force and
questions well around his treatment of
political opponents and critical
journalists Putin he's unwilling to sit
back be a shrinking violet on the world
stage
ensuring Russia remains a world power
with a great deal of influence he has
done all that he can to cultivate an
image of strength both for Russia as a
country and for himself personally
showing no signs of stopping his
adventurous and daredevil lifestyle even
as he enters his 60s Vladimir Putin he
has undoubtedly made a place for himself
in world history and with him eligible
for re-election in 2018 we may still
have many years of Putin on the world
stage ahead of us so I hope you like the
video if you didn't you know what to do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe below we put out
brand new videos twice a week so
subscribe for more things just like this
if you did like them also over there on
the right a couple of other videos that
you might like to check out if you
enjoyed this one and as always thank you
for watching